انه اكبر الغاز عالم الطيران على الاطلاق
في الثامن من مارس عام 2014 اختفت الرحله
رقم 370 التابعه لخطوط الطيران الماليزيه
والتي كانت في طريقها الى بكيد ابراج
المراقبه الجويه فقدت الاتصال بالطائره
بينما كانت فوق بحر جنوب الصين وكل
محاولات الاتصال لاحقا بقت بالفشل اليوم
وبعد تسع سنوات وعمليات بحث استمرت لاكثر
من اربع سنوات شاركت فيها 30 دوله
وتكلفت نحو 150 مليون دولار لا اثر
للطائره ولا لصندوقها الاسود الطائره التي
اختفت والفايخ جديد من ثلاث حلقات اطلقته
نتفليكس في ذكرى الرحله الغامضه التي كانت
تنقل 239 شخصا من العاصمه الماليزيه
ومنذ اختفائها طرحت العديد من الفرضيات
وصلت الى تخيل مخلوقات فضائيه المزيد حول
ابرز النظريات لاختفاء الطائره الماليزيه
الطائره الماليزيه المنكوبه التي اختفت
عام 2014 احاط بها الكثير من التكهنات
وسيل لا يحصى من تحليلات الخبراء وغير
الخبراء هناك نظريه تقول ان قائد الطائره
اختطف طائرته بقصد الهروب الى منطقه لا
تلتقطها اشارات الرادار لكنه عجز عن تنفيذ
الخطه وتوفي مع الركاب سيناريو اخر وهو ان
الطائره اختطفت على يد احد الركاب حيث كان
هناك راكبان يسافران بجوازي سفر مسروقين
لكن تم اعتبارهما مهاجرين غيري نظامين لا
اكثر وليس ارهابيين روايه اخرى تقول ان
الطائره تعرضت لعمليه اختطاف عن بعد حيث
يتحكم مجرم في الطائره من على الارض ويمنع
اي شخص على متنها من تغيير الوجهه التي
يحددها ما يعرف بالارهاب السيبراني لكن
يظل التصور الاقرب الذي اتفق عليه ان قائد
الط ائره اراد ان ينهي حياته فاوقف تشغيل
جهاز الارسال والاستقبال وقام بتغيير ضغط
الطائره ما ادى الى وفاه جميع الركاب بسبب
نقص الاكسجين قبل ان تغرق في جنوب المحيط
الهندي من بيروت ينضم الينا طيار فادي
رمضان اهلا بك كابتن معنا بعد تسع سنوات
من اختفائها الغامض برايكم الذي حل
بالطائره الماليزيه
مرحبا اول شيء بدي بس قول شي واحد بخصوص
الوثائق اللي حضروا الناس على الناس فليكس
الوسائقي بيعمل عده تكهنات اللي مش مزبوطه
هي اول وحده منهم انه ولا طائره بالعالم
بالتاريخ اختفت بهالطريقه وهذا الشيء خطا
في كتير طائرات بالعالم اختفوا كليا
بدون اي عثور على اي ادله يعني مثلا في
عنا نعمه حتى ب 2015 طائره سبيس 125 اختفت
مع سبعه الركاب تبعولها شي مكان بالمحيط
وكليا اختفت فالفكره انه معقول تختفي
الطائره بهذا القرض مع كل التكنولوجيا
الموجوده عنا حاليا منو شيء كثير بعيد عن
بتصير بس نفهم يعني انت بتستبعد انه تكون
اختفت يعني وين مثلا في هي وقعت بمسطح
مائي ويتشاطئ على كثير من الدول معقول ولا
دوله قدرت تشوف ادله او ترصد سقوط مثلا
جسم ساقط من من السماء
الكره الارضيه كتير كبيره
شي نحن كانسان يمكن عنا الصعوبه نتفهم
قديش حجم الكره الارضيه على العالم
منشوفها انا كبيره بس على الواطي بتطلع
علينا بتشوفها قدامنا قليله صغيره البحر
المنطقه الطائر اختفت فيها منطقه كتير
كتير كتير كبيره بحجم امريكا يعني كانك عم
تحطي شيء انت كل قاره الامريكانيه وحده
وحده والتكنولوجيا كمان نحن شفنا قطعه من
الطائره بلشوا يطلعوا يعني هم بالوثائقي
اللي ما بيعرف بالوثائق بفرجونا لا
بالوثائق بفرجونا قطعه واحده الفلاتر بس
ما ذكروا سيره الرايت اوت اللي كان عنده
اللي طلع بعد فتره طلع يمكن
في معلومات ناقصه
كابتن فادي انت طيار وقدرى بما يحصل داخل
الطائرات يعني من بين النظريات المطروحه
اتهامات لكابت الطائره انه تعمد اسقاطها
خصوصا انه قام بانزال جهاز الهبوط قبل ان
تغرق الطائره ما رايكم بهذه الفرضيه مثلا
[موسيقى]
صراحه لسوء الحظ اكثر فرضيه وارده هي
الفرضيه انه يكون الطيار اللي عمل العمليه
لعده اسباب انه
طفى الاجهزه الاجهزه التواصل
الطائره فجاه اختفت عن كل
عن الانظمه السايبر اتاك الهجوم القرصنه
مستحيل حتى يفوت بقره تبع
ويقدر يعمل كمان
مستحيله ما بتصير هيك ما في الطيار بس
بيمسك بيعلن اعلان انذارات وبتنكسف القصه
كل القصص الوارده الثانيه ما بيزبطوا فيهم
مشاكل الفكره
جربت تعمل شي مؤامره انه تغير المعلومات
كمان مش وارده لانه التكنولوجيا المستعمل
للطريقه اللي تم استعمالها كانت اول مره
باستعملها بطريقه
يعني اكثر شيء لسوق الحازين معقول يكون
على الارجح اختطاف لسوق الحظ
طيار شخص يعني انا بعرف انت مش دكتور نفسي
بس يعني بسيكولوجيه
القوائق قائد قائدي الطيران لما في كابتن
يقرر انه يسقي الطائره ويقتل اكثر من 200
شخص معه يعني شو الرساله اللي بده يوصلها
لشركه الطيران او للبلد يعني بس هيك ممكن
نقدر نقرب الصوره
حنكون صريحين اوكي الطيار يعمل عمليه
انتحاريه لسوق الحظ صايره كتير نادرا
بالصايره قبل بمره ورجعت صارت من بعد
حادثه
الماليزيه 370 مثلا وينجز الضابط الاول
شو اسمه قفل باب قمره القياده وانتحر
وخشيال معه كل الناس موجودين لا الله
يرحمهم كلهم من بعد ما صارت الحاسب على
وينز وتم التاكيد 100% انه كانت عمليه
الانتحار ايازه وقتها وكل بقيه العالم
طلعوا اجراءات جديده هلا غير الامتحانات
الطبيه
والسايكولوجيكيه نحن بنعملها يلي دائما
بنعملها من زمان لهلا بنعملها بس مثل
بيقولوا في احيانا محلات بطلوا يعملوها
ايام زمان على كل حال اطلعوا 2016 بعطي
ايد على انه او 15 انه يصير في دائما يكون
في شخصين مكفلين بالطياره يعني
حدا لحاله بغرفه القياده لسوق الحظ ب 2017
او 2016 يعني السنه الاجراء رجعوا قالوا
مش مضطرين هلا نحن عنا بالشركه طول عمرنا
موجوده وما بنشيلها بحياتنا لانه بغض
النظر بركه صار شيء اي شيء ما فيك تعفش
معه يصير لما يكون شخص لحاله بغرفه قياده
فقط لنختم هل انت مع فرضيه الغرق في
المحيط ام الخطف خصوصا انه الطائره اختفت
في ظل الغموض لا اكيد وصلت للمحيط يعني
المسار اللي شفتوها المسار اللي بتشوفوه
اللي متفق عليه هذا المسار هو اكثر شيء
مزبوط لانه عنا عده عده ادله عليها يلي
بيساعدونا نوصل لوين الطياره كابتن فادي
اليوم اهالي الطائره يطالبون بالمزيد
والمزيد من البحث عن فك هذا اللغز الذي
حير العالم هل يمكن بعد مضيء كل هذه
السنوات وهل نحن يعني عام بعد عام نفقد
القدره على الوصول الى
الحلفت لقدره كل ما يمرق الوقت الا اذا
تكنولوجيا فيها تمسح البحر كلياته بس ما
عنا هالتكنولوجيا لانه البحر كثير كبير
والتكنولوجيا تبعتنا بعدها كتير متاخره اه
لسوء الحظ في كثير مرات بالتاريخ البشريه
بصير معنا حاسه كثير كبيره واخر شيء
مضطرين نوصل للواقع انه
الواقع هو انه عم نحكي نحن عن طياره كتير
صغيره بمحيط كثير كبير حتى مش مؤكدين باي
منطقه بالمحيط بدنا نفتش شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه التوضيحات من بيروت الطيار فادي
رمضان شكرا كابتن